Columbo is still not safe we'd gone to
st. Anthony's one of the churches bombed
on Easter Sunday mid-afternoon a car was
found abandoned the police pushing
people back we've been told it's
dangerous we believe that the suspect
vehicle is that white one over there
were being asked to move back everyone
here very nervous very jumpy very on
edge people running through the streets
an officer from Sri Lanka's
counterterrorism special task force told
us it was a car bomb the bomb squad laid
out charges as we scrambled for cover
the detonation the same controlled
explosion caught from another angle
[Music]
as the dust came down things were
chaotic and confused shrapnel everywhere
we've gone quite a way back from where
the explosion was he's still picking up
bits of shrapnel on this yard I mean
that's just lethal on the same street
earlier the funeral of one victim this
is his son yesterday he went to church
with his father he was clearly still in
shock this grief was even fresher now
the mortuary relatives were here to
identify their family members van after
van came to take home the dead at the
moment do you know it's a terrible
situation we need a lot of
reconciliation on one hand people we
have people who are really suffering
with this terrible grief on the other
hand we have people who are living it
fear what can happen next
among the hundreds of victims were
Western tourists talk did buy bombs at
hotels in the city center the
billionaire owner of ASOS and as Hulk
Paulson lost three of his four children
a British woman and her 11 year old son
are feared to be among the victims
Anita Nicholson and her son Alex I
thought have been at the shangri-la
hotel when it was attacked
the clock on st. Anthony's Church
stopped when the bomb went off
this was Sri Lanka's worst terror attack
since his bloody civil war a decade ago
but the country cannot yet warn when the
danger still feels plus Tom Tasha Sky
News number